其中一个做法，就是把用户输入前的等待时间当成预加载的机会。
所以你在设置一台机器时会回答五个问题。
这样它就在后台做事了。
我们就在后台干活。这一点我一开始根本没想到，其实这是最老套的招数了。很多电子游戏早就这么干了——让玩家去操作，
同时在后台做预加载之类的。所以这是很自然的老技术，但我就是没往安装程序上想。我原本以为，得先问用户密码、用户名
和时区这些，然后再开始干活。可实际上，这些完全可以预加载。另外就是一堆调整，改的是安装程序本身做事的顺序。还有些
就是把它缩小。上一版Omarchy有7.5GB，而如今大部分时间其实都花在解压压缩包上。ISO里主要就是这些东西，安装时间也主要耗在这儿。所以
把它缩到——我记得现在是5.85GB，减得相当可观。几乎是一比一地转化，我在那儿做了些挺有意思的事。比如用了JetBrains字体，很棒的字体，很漂亮，而
其实这字体我第一眼并不喜欢，但后来它成了唯一能在Mitchell Azimodo的Ghostty里显示完美的字体。Ghostty不知为何就是不肯按我习惯的方式渲染我心爱的Bitstream Vera Sans，
但它渲染这个JetBrains字体却完美无缺。所以我就换了。但Arch上JetBrains字体的标准包有200MB，因为里面包含了各种变体、各种子类型之类的。
然后我意识到，这些我们根本用不上。我们用的只是等宽版本，而且是打过nerd font补丁的那种。你知道那才多大吗？我印象里是16MB。
于是我就干脆搞了个新包，JetBrains的精简版。就这一下，直接省了180MB。我就这么一路做下来，重复了好多次。Nvidia
驱动也这么处理。Nvidia驱动直接从Arch仓库拿下来时，并没有用最极致的压缩方式，我记得叫ZSTD，这种压缩很慢，慢在创建压缩包的时候，但如果你是在构建软件包，那时间多的是，只要能因此缩小ISO就行。所以光那两个Nvidia包，我们大概就省了200MB。
慢在生成压缩包，但构建软件包时你有的是时间，只要最后能缩小ISO就行。所以光那两个Nvidia包，我们大概就省了200MB。
嗯。我喜欢这个的原因是，我把自己想象成迈凯伦的汽车设计师。迈凯伦现在造的是世界上最轻的超级跑车之一，他们对从车上抠掉每一克重量简直到了痴迷的程度。
每一克都要省。所以哪怕是最新的750S迈凯伦，也比竞争对手轻得多。他们用碳纤维单体壳，这让他们胜过用铝的比如法拉利。但他们还就是有这种
对重量的执念。我看过迈凯伦的人接受记者采访，说我们在这个零件上省了370克，我当时就想，等等，一辆车大概1040公斤
或者1380公斤什么的，他们居然在乎370克。
是啊，
真是群偏执的疯子。我爱他们。我想要这种精神。就冲这个，我都想要一辆迈凯伦。
就因为这个。所以那一刻，当我一MB一MB地从软件包里抠重量时，我想，哥们，我有点像迈凯伦的汽车开发师了。虽然我们说真的，这活儿还没干完，包还能再缩。但这其实牵扯到我们和传统Linux社区之间的另一个冲突——臃肿。
包还能再缩。但这其实牵扯到我们和传统Linux社区之间的另一个冲突——臃肿。
在某些圈子里，预装软件其实是不合规矩的，因为凭什么由你来替大家决定该用什么程序？我就想说，老兄，名字里都写着呢。它叫Omarchy，那个om部分
是omic ac的缩写，字面意思就是'主厨精选'。我就是主厨，我来做选择。而这就是我认为超棒的一套应用。顺便说一句，里面还带视频编辑器，预装了OBS
用来录屏。就在里面，OBS是预装的。
Caden Live 是个视频剪辑时间线编辑器，很好用。我所有视频都用它剪。然后我自己做了个片段剪辑器。你提过同步那事。我搞了这个剪辑工具。比如我录了期播客或者
别的什么。我要给某个内容剪个片段，用 Caden Live 或别的时间线编辑器挺麻烦的。所以我做了 Cut。
Cut 也包含在内。它就是专门做片段的，整个操作都能用键盘搞定。你可以跳到准确的时间点，然后按 Control 加空格。它就把剪辑线移到那条线上。然后你到
片段的结尾，按 Alt 加空格，它就把结束线移过去。然后按 Ctrl S 保存。现在用 Cut 我剪片段快得离谱。太惊人了。但是，它上面装了所有软件。有 Neovim。有 her。有
Tmux。有终端。有一堆主题。有一堆呃背景图。是我能挑出来的最好的。这占了一些空间。应该占，因为这不应该是那种荒芜的界面，让你
什么都得自己重建。这应该是一套开箱即用的高效系统。它用什么写的？
其实主要是用 bash 写的，Linux 配置那部分。Bash 干这个是很棒的语言。它呃就是为这个而生的，真的就是系统管理。它也有局限。你不该什么都用 bash 写。
智能体生成 bash 怎么样？挺好的。
哦，惊人。除了一件事，我每次逮到就得拍智能体的后脑勺，提醒它去看 agents 的 MD 文件，因为我在里面写了指令，不让它
搞提前退出。智能体特喜欢用前置条件，而不是完全展开的条件判断。我喜欢那种写着如果这样那就那样的。智能体喜欢前置条件或者退出，再来个前置条件或者退出，最后才落到它真正想做的事上。
我我讨厌那种风格。所以，
除了这点，它已经好得吓人、好得惊人，好到上次我们聊的时候，聊到我会让智能体写个 bash 的东西，然后我自己敲进去，结果我有点
记不住。后来我费劲确保那些能力没从我指缝里流走。所以，我其实自己学会了写 bash，而现在我自己一行 bash 都不写了。我大概好几个月没自己写过任何 bash
了，因为智能体变得太好了，你只要给它们几点风格上的指点，偶尔对复杂度推回去就行。这个我前几天在推特上说过。
让我震惊的是，智能体常常做完一件事，说完成了，再让另一个智能体审查，它们也说完成了，然后我说，这个对我来说看着有点太复杂了。然后它就会说，‘哦，对，你说得
对。你说得对。我完全把这搞复杂了，然后它就把代码砍掉一半。’我说，‘它就不能一开始就这么做吗？’然后有人提醒我，人类也一样。如果你做一样东西，
别人来审查，他们就说，‘看着有点复杂。’很多时候你就能说，‘啊，[清嗓]你说得对。’看，就这些小迹象在我看来说明程序员还是需要的，那种
直觉。因为我觉得，你说什么来着？我对代码的全貌有一种感觉。
当我做像 Amachi 这样的东西时，我确实会看代码。
我看它的形状，看它的比例。
就像我不用再自己凿每一处了。这又是我自我吹捧的时候。一刻我还只是迈凯伦的音响工程师，下一刻我就是达芬奇，带着整个工作室的学生，他们在
精良的大理石上凿刻，而他说，啊不对，比例不太对。现在和智能体一起工作就是这种感觉，我能像编辑那样给反馈，
就是，你知道吗，我不会什么都自己写，但我能告诉你什么时候论证不成立。我能告诉你什么时候形状和问题不成比例，或者什么时候它就是感觉太复杂了。
而且惊人地常常，它就这么成了。就像早期那个笑话是别犯错。我觉得现在不用再跟智能体说这个了，因为现在的框架太好了。它们跑自动化测试。它们能得到
那些反馈。但你确实还得告诉它们，弄简单点。
你会用语音来交互吗，还是你大部分时间都在打字？你打字多吗？
我全部都打字。其实我用的是 Inomachi 内置的语音转文字功能，真的挺好用的。我只是发现
我不是那样思考的，我自己都惊讶，我不喜欢跟电脑说话。在车里的时候我喜欢，但坐在键盘前面，我就只想打字。而且我就是喜欢打字。你用语音吗？
我是个内向的人，不喜欢社交，也不喜欢说话。
我觉得我也有这部分。但对我来说，不知道为什么，语音特别强大。我想给你看看这个。我用的这个东西叫 Plaude。我就把它挂在我，呃，挂在T恤上这里。你按
一个按钮，它就开始录音。
从心流角度来说，这其实比坐在电脑前体验好多了。而且我，嗯，通常都是智能体生成的问题，我真的很想好好讨论一下。所以我会写程序、我会说一段很长的提示词，
很多都是意识流推理。有时候我中途会改变对某个设计的想法，但所有这些都在里面。然后我用一个 LLM 来处理，用 Plaude。显然有
API 可以获取，转录，清理转录文本，因为你会想要它，因为我会提到文件。我会提到技术概念，比如文件和函数等等，你要确保转录
语音转文字能正确识别。所以你需要一个词典。处理文件时你要了解代码库。
然后你就有了这个巨大的东西，经常是我花10、15、20分钟讨论整个设计。我发现这真的非常强大，因为它没有过度指定的问题，因为
系统对你在想象什么有大量的意识流思考。这对设计的早期阶段特别好。比如我想从零开始做一个东西，最初阶段我会从头到尾说一遍，
可能得说上一个小时。有些提示词我讲了一个小时，就是一直不停地说。
我强烈建议大家试试用语音连续说很长时间，
而不是那种——对，我没这么用过，可能是我用得不对。我一般就是打两句话或者讲两句话，然后就有点烦躁，觉得这些我打字也一样快。但我还真没试过
这种一口气连续说20分钟的做法。
嘿，尤其是你，因为你说话特别快。
对。不，我能理解。我一直在试着用它来干些比如回邮件之类的事，一开始觉得能帮上忙，确实也有点用，但后来它会犯个小
错，我还得去改。但如果你是对着一个根本不在乎这些杂七杂八的LLM做意识流输出，那大概就顺畅多了。这里面有两件事要做。第一，好，
你把原始音频转成文字。我用的是ElevenLabs做转录，它们大概是最好的语音转文字模型。但那里还是会有错。所以你需要一个能访问词典的提示词，让它能
这个词典你怎么建？
首先，这是一个跟你相关的术语词典。然后让它知道——你可以做个智能体，当你聊到代码时，它会去翻你整个代码库，找出你常用的关键术语。还有，
当你聊到消息、Gmail、WhatsApp这些的时候，它能知道你所有联系人和你常弄错的那些词。
你在这上面真是下足了功夫。
对我来说，这是个必须解决的问题，因为
你可能会遇到的一个问题是，语音转文字有时候会出错。
没错，那我就没法用它来口述邮件了。
对，如果它从不出错，
那就会更有吸引力。
是啊。而且你不介意它不是完全实时。其实你可以接受等上5秒。我不知道你的使用场景是什么，我能接受等5秒、10秒让它处理完所有内容。
你得凭感觉把这个做成一个应用，能搞定所有这些事，
让它直接就能用。
我记得私下跟你提过，让我很惊讶的是，翻译并没有做到完美，
对吧？语音到语音的翻译。
看起来你把所有这些拼在一起，已经非常接近可能达到的极限了。
但是，你知道，当你真要发布这种东西的时候，确实得开始考虑延迟问题。
别让完美成为好的敌人。我是说，如果你突然让一件事变得可行，而人们以前根本做不了，那多花5秒也没关系。我觉得这正是史蒂夫·乔布斯特别擅长的地方，
他意识到第一代iPhone在各方面都很糟糕，对吧？数据连接慢得可怕，性能严重不足，什么都差。但产品太有吸引力了，
所以这些就都不重要了。如果你非要等到一切都刚刚好、完美无缺才发布，那就太晚了。如果你解决的是人们目前没有解决方案的问题，他们愿意给它5秒。如果
你处在竞争激烈的市场，那确实不一样，但那意味着问题已经被解决了，你根本不需要再去解决它。
嗯，我确实觉得有几个，比如Whisper Flow就非常好。已经有一些人在语音转文字这块站出来了。
对，对。我们之前用的是Box Type，是开源的。
没错。它只是用了某个开源模型。我忘了是哪个Parrot模型之类的。它对短命令效果挺好的。所以我就用它来干这个。我想你只要按住F9，它就开始听写。
哦，所以它已经内置在里面了。
你只需要联网。它会提示你安装Box Type包，因为那个包里包含一个150兆的模型。我当时就想，啊，不知道我能不能装得下。
所以，
对，
我们默认没有把它放进去。但我们留了选项。其实我昨天还在想，我们真的需要把所有这些整合起来。所以Umachi Quattro作为一个可塑的操作系统，真的太惊人了，
你可以直接跟你的智能体说话就给它加功能。
但这正是我们应该做的。很多人会觉得跟电脑说话很自然，就说：'嘿，能给我做个股票面板吗？我想追踪苹果和戴尔。'然后就能看到
你完全可以通过语音来操控agent，无论是输入还是输出，然后你的操作系统就彻底变了。这就是钢铁侠里贾维斯的愿景，各种定制应用就那么神奇地冒出来。
我觉得AI里真正让我着迷的领域是那种实时游戏模型。不知道你看过没有，AI在实时生成下一帧画面，但你真的可以玩这个游戏。我觉得如果
它们能做到这个，那我们为什么不能用操作系统这么干？为什么我们不能直接跟它说话，让它换个样子或者改点什么，然后一切就都变了？顺便说一句，我觉得这是另一个即将带来
Linux全面统治的突破。agent已经把诊断Linux系统的所有痛苦都消除了，把Linux那种过度具体、完全晦涩的错误信息变成了它最大的优势。
当Linux出问题时，agent能拿到那条对普通人来说完全看不懂的非常具体的错误信息，然后结合一个事实——agent预训练了四千万行Linux代码。
所以它知道该去哪儿找，然后精准定位。从今年年初到现在，我的Linux机器上没出过一个agent诊断不了的问题。一年半前可不是这样。一年半
前，我还在论坛上搜那些冷门问题的答案。现在，agent不光知道Linux操作系统的源代码，我机器上每一个软件的源代码它都能访问。
所有这些东西的源代码它都有。其实这是我在发布前刚加进去的一个功能。一旦你设好默认agent，
Umachi Quattro有个崩溃检测功能。如果你机器上任何应用崩了，它会弹出一个小提示，问你要不要让AI来诊断这个问题。
嗯，
太厉害了。
简直不可思议。我见过一些情况，某个子系统报错，甚至不是Linux本身，只是我装的某个应用出错，agent就开始翻日志，查systemd日志，然后去扒那个崩溃应用的源代码。
定位到是某个Rust文件第472行，有个没有边界检查的unwrap变量溢出了之类的，然后问你要不要提交一个bug报告，附带所有这些细节。
我给你讲个特别棒的故事。我当时在跟一个叫JDX的人合作，他在做MIS这个包管理器，专门用于快速迭代的开发工具。我们就是用这个来管理所有agent软件的。普通包管理器
不是为了一天更新七次设计的，而所有这些agent框架差不多一天要更新七次。所以我们需要一个带外包管理器，MIS正好完美适合这个场景。总之，它有个小bug。
有个竞态条件，而agent特别擅长发现这种问题，因为当你同时跑多个agent时，它们会把你底层基础设施里所有那些人类手动操作从没触发过的竞态条件都揪出来。
所以它发现了这个问题，对吧？我跟agent说，嘿，你能把这个作为bug报告发到JDX的GitHub上吗？结果不巧的是，就在那之前，我让它对
Amachi本身做了一次QA测试，用了八个不同的agent。它发现了28个真实的问题需要提交。结果它跑到GitHub上，试图同时提交这全部28个问题，大概用了……我也说不清，12秒吧。
GitHub就把它标记为疑似垃圾信息，这也不算不合理，然后封了我的omachi机器人账号。然后我就没法操作了。机器人被禁止访问GitHub了。所以我就跟它说，嘿，你知道吗，直接发邮件
给JDX吧。这是他的邮箱地址。我之前已经给它配了一个hey.com的邮箱。我们有个
命令行工具现在还在beta阶段。所以我给它配上了这个。这样它就能发邮件了。它就是用这个给我发未解决问题的报告和PR的。于是它就给JDX发了封邮件，说了它发现的bug。JDX就说，等等，这是
我第一次收到未发布软件的bug报告。因为它下载了MIS的源代码，发现他已经修了这个bug，但这个问题在他们还没发布的软件里并没有被完全修复。
对，
精准定位了问题，他就说，
"我去，我还没发版本就收到bug报告了。
达到令人难以置信的AGI水平
惊世骇俗的东西。” 其实如果你还记得，当时有一个悬而未决的问题：AI系统能不能很好地调试？大家的想法是，写代码当然可以，但它们能找到问题吗？
它们在这方面实在太厉害了。这其实挺有意思，因为我当时可能也站在那一边，有点怀疑它能不能推理这一切。后来Shopify的CTO米凯尔做了一项
科学研究，我记得是去年年底或今年年初，他让智能体回溯Shopify生产环境中所有的事故，包括宕机和其他问题，追溯到
合并的那个PR，然后查清楚：由人工审查的PR和由智能体审查的PR，哪个质量更高。结果呢，企业级……
由智能体审查的PR在生产中引起的问题更少。而这还是用我们六个月前的模型测的。到现在，在我们今天工作的大多数领域里，100%可以肯定，智能体更擅长找bug。
那你现在整天都在跑智能体。你觉得哪个模型更出色？目前谁领先？这似乎一直在变。Soul、Fable、Gro 46、Gemini、中国的开放权重模型。让我惊讶的是，你能一口气说出
这么多不同的竞争者，这个市场如此开放，领先位置真的会来回易主，我们有了真正的竞争，有那么多实验室能够达到前沿或接近前沿。这
顺便说一句，太了不起了。我至今也没完全搞懂。但回答你的问题，目前总体上最好的模型是Fable。嗯。
在我看来第二好的模型是Opus 5。但仅次于Opus 5的那一档，而且它们也不总是排在后面，有时还会领先。
我一会儿会说到。我会把GPT Soul排得很高。
嗯。
Gro 46我几天前刚开始测试。我碰巧搞出了一个绝妙的测试：我把一个Python库翻译成了Rust，就是你刚看到的那个带各种酷炫动画的屏幕保护程序，它原本是由
一个叫terminal text effects的Python库驱动的。非常酷的库。我们从Omachi第一天起就在用它。
问题是它是用Python写的。所以启动的时候，尤其在手提电脑上，它用Python运行，会占满你的CPU来做这些效果，因此大约要耗30瓦的电，而且
风扇狂转，电池也耗得飞快。
嗯。
在台式机上无所谓，但在笔记本上就有关系了。所以我想，你知道吗？这听起来正是Rust该解决的问题。于是我先把挑战交给Fable，我只告诉它：这是
这个Python库的源代码，这个TD8库有一堆依赖之类的。我想要一个Rust版本，零依赖，单个可执行文件。Rust就是干这个的。所以基本上，我要Rust版。我要
它逐帧像素级完美。做完整分析。不完成就别停。
好。
这就是提示词。
不骗你，不到45分钟，叮的一声。我听到它说。
我完成了。我全都检查过了。我把启动时间从86毫秒降到了2毫秒。执行速度提升了9.6倍，我记得是这个数。可执行文件只有3兆。你要不要跑一下？
太棒了。
于是我就运行了它。
天哪。我也不知道为什么我还会惊讶，因为这种翻译工作我们早就知道AI很擅长了。但对我来说仍然很震撼：我竟然能一次性把
我用了一年、别人用了更久的Python库完整翻译出来，变成一个Rust可执行文件——我完全不懂Rust，连Rust代码都没看一眼，就做出了这个可执行文件，然后我告诉智能体
行，太好了，发布吧。它把它打包成一个新包，问我想叫什么名字。呃，就叫TTFX吧。创建新的git仓库，它就建好了git仓库。再创建一个新的构建包
给我们的构建系统用。它把它推送上去，发布出去，再给自己开一个pull request。我们就从Python实现的TTE切换到TTFX，它全搞定了。我就坐在那儿，那时候我已经被智能体的加速能力彻底
冲昏头脑了。我还是得往后一靠，心想：这就是AGI吧？AGI大概就是这个样子。如果这些时刻能一直发生，那就是AGI。
据我理解，你还不只用Fable重复了这个实验。
我在所有模型上都试了。先说个好玩的事。我用Fable的token用到三分之二就用完了，它就自动切换到Opus 5继续干，把活干完了。我觉得它能做到的部分原因是，
Fable做的第一件事是制定了一个计划，而且是非常详细的计划。我记得有八个独立步骤：这里你这么做，这里你分析它，这里你运行效果等等，所以
我根本没审查这个计划，也没改。它就是自己做了计划，所以Opus能接手。然后我想，既然Opus能完成，也许其他智能体也能完成。所以第一件事
我就是把它交给了——我记得是交给了Saul。
嗯。
Saul也把活干完了，但花了两倍时间。我记得大概一个半小时。但关键是：按token算的成本。我不是按token付费的，我订的是Cloud的max订阅，对吧？所以它是在订阅范围内完成的，
它用光了我所有的token，我不得不切换到Opus 5。但如果按token付费，我估计整件事要550美元。我想了一下，天哪，太划算了。如果我自己
要学会Rust并熟练到能做这个翻译，我得花九个月。我可以花500美元让这个翻译发生，然后突然得到10倍的执行速度提升。这我绝对愿意花500美元。但是但是
竞争嘛。所以我又给了Saul。同样的计划。公平地说，我没让Saul做计划，我只是把Fable的计划拿过来给了Saul。
Saul用一个半小时、大概46美元6的token成本重复了这个任务。
对。
做了同样的事。
嗯。
我心想，哇塞，太厉害了。然后我就贪心了。
对。于是我问了GPT Luna，就是OpenAI那个超级便宜的模型。你能做吗？完全不行。首先，它根本不想开始任务。我记得大概是
春天的时候，我们不再需要那些斜杠goal之类的东西了。只要你告诉智能体别停，它们就能自动循环继续干下去。所以
Saul能做到，Fable能做到，但Luna不行。所以我大概发了12次提示，一直让它去做，最后我算是把它启动起来了。它做的第一件事就是作弊。它第一件看的事
在它自己的目录之外，看到那里已经有一个别的实现了，于是就在外面简单包了一层，说：搞定了。太搞笑了。但它没能收尾，因为它只改了几个地方，
但我的意思是，好吧，那我不能这么干。然后我把它交给了 Grock 4.6，
之前我用过一点 Grock 4.5，我当时觉得，嗯，有人尝试是挺酷的，但我不会用，因为它感觉落后太多了。Grock 4.6 完成了任务。
速度快了 10 倍，可执行文件大小一样，按 token 计费大概是 55 美元。
简直难以置信。然后我用 Kim K3 又重做了一遍第二项。
它跑了超级久。我忘了 Kimmy 到底花了多长时间。然后我也用 Deep Seek V4 Flash 试了一遍，Flash 失败的方式跟 Luna 一样，它做不到。之后我又用 Pro 试，Pro 也完成了
任务。花了 2 小时 45 分钟、23 美元。所以现在情况就是这样，对吧？Fable 明显最好。它最快，是它写出的方案，但要 550 美元，输出结果却一样。
其他的，Grock 差不多，成本大概是它十分之一。
嗯。
Deepseek 是它成本的 120 分之一。但你得多等一会儿。简直厉害得让人拍案叫绝。顺便说一句，我先让 Fable 完成了第一项任务，然后 Opus 也完成了。那是第一次一发命中，对吧？快了 10 倍。
我做了两轮自动研究，其实现在都不算自动研究了。你都不用打斜杠命令，只要告诉它一直继续，直到你说停。
最后我想我们相对原始版本实现了 46 倍的执行速度提升。
太厉害了。
嗯，你知道，我只是觉得在规划方面没有什么能跟Fable比。所以我通常用Fable来做规划和审查，然后用别的东西来实现，比如Opus 5。它
真的很好。这套组合真的很棒，能让你不太容易把token用光。
我发现一件很有意思的事，因为Fable在我看来是目前最好的模型，但它也会犯错。而想要做出最好的软件，我其实更愿意让两个来自不同来源的
我的意思是它们不是中端货，它们都是顶尖的，但比如说让Opus 5和Codeex
让一个去检查另一个的活儿。这是我现在的标准操作流程。我会
让Opus或Fable来干活，然后我总是用codeex x high来收尾审查
我还开始用grock，就是想试试看。它也挺不错的，总能挑出问题来。当我在自己机器上让我的agent干活时，这就是我的工作流。然后我推到GitHub上，接着Copilot——不骗你
它真的变好了。Copilot总能发现真正坏掉的地方，这也是一种惊人的加速，因为最早开始干这事的Copilot版本简直就是在
乱标一通。你每推一次，它就一遍又一遍标同一个问题。真的很烦人。所以我觉得很多人最后干脆把它关了。如果他们真关了，应该重新打开
因为它现在真的挺不错。总能找出问题。然后如果你把那个
我们不该感到惊讶。有什么好惊讶的？就算你是个好程序员，做完一个活儿之后找个同样很厉害的同行来审查，你最后得到的代码肯定会更好。当然，最后就是
用更好的代码。所以，把这个融入你的工作流程。选一个代理来主用。我主要用 Claude 来驱动，这其实挺有意思，因为我对 Anthropic 有些别的保留意见。
但我坚持用 Claude 的原因是，在我看来，他们的框架确实最好。它之所以是最好的框架之一，是因为支持多代理同时运行。所以如果你想同时跑多个代理，你
在会话里按左箭头，就回到代理视图。在代理视图里，你可以再挑一个代理。所以如果你想同时开多条线，
Cloud Code 就是最顺手的配置。而且他们总是稍微领先一点，这其实也不该让人意外。我是说，Boris，参与这项目的人之一，基本上是他最先搞出这
个东西的。有意思的是，这个优势一直保持至今。我也大量用过 Open Code。我觉得 Open Code 很棒。我主要把 Open Code 当作所有开源模型的主框架。比如 Kimi K3 之类的。而且我不在
中国服务器上做推理。我在 Fireworks 上推理，这是个很好的服务，按 token 付费就行。如果你用的是这些开放权重模型，按 token 算并不算贵。所以这是个很好的方式去
做这件事。但我不觉得我会——好吧，也许我会，但如果用 Claude 的订阅制，那感觉就像捡了大便宜，简直是疯狂地划算。
对。而且我实际上有四个。
我今早刚注册了第二个。对。
因为我倒时差四点就醒了，然后马上开始用代理干活。现在我离 Fable 的额度重置还有三天，结果我用完了。
所以他们真的应该
我是说，我不懂为什么这要搞得这么复杂？你不能直接把订阅叠加起来吗？为什么我要登录好几次？
而且显然你得开发某种工具。
对，我也做了
从一个切到另一个。而且
顺便说一句，我们正把这个做进 Machi。所以下一版 Machi 会自带多订阅支持。
对。我希望那些实验室干脆让你一次买个一百份 Max 订阅。
这其实挺有意思的，对我来说，因为用 Grok 4.6 然后再切到 Claude Code 对我来说非常挑战，因为 Grok 太快了。
对，这就是关键。Grok 的关键在于他们的快速模式比别家的普通模式还便宜。当你用过 Grok 4.6 的快速模式，会有点上瘾，因为它几乎让你进入这种单线程
模式，代理能跟得上你。
对。但我不知道我怎么能——一旦我习惯了 Claude Code
呃，我就受不了 Grok 的速度
因为我现在习惯了多任务并行。于是
现在我又回到那种切换来切换去的焦虑状态。所以，这一切都是个学习过程，学习编程到底应该是什么样子。
顺便说，我不确定这些框架最终会是什么形态，原因之一是我们已经在 Basecamp 开始实验的一件事：把代理放进 Basecamp 里，把它们当作
同事，然后我们在 Base Camp 里给他们分配任务。他们会在 Base Camp 里处理待办事项，或者处理某张卡片。结果发现，一个为异步沟通优化的协作工具，其实才是正确的
格式。而这些框架更像聊天，而聊天——我的意思是，这些东西最初的格式并不合适，因为你坐在那儿干等。它会诱使你坐着等。而当你处理
像 Base Camp 这样的东西时，你可以直接给一个智能体一个待办事项，你并不指望它立刻回复。所以我不知道最终形态会变成什么样，但我一直在用所有这些框架。我在
Herder 里用它们，而 Herder 有分屏面板。所以经常我会在上面跑 Claude，然后在下面跑 Codex，也许我还开着 OpenCode。但我要说，最近我发现，人在回路才是这里的
瓶颈。所以我开始搭建更多自动化系统。我一直在做一个 AMA 机器人，它能在 Amachi 上做更自主的开发，就是按固定时间表处理所有待办、PR 和 issue，
然后用 hey CLI 给我发邮件，我就收到这封邮件：这里有 12 个 PR，要么可以合并了，要么我觉得你该关掉，然后我在那里做最终决定。
你觉得这种多任务、任务切换，在精神上让人疲惫吗？
会，但是一种令人兴奋的方式。就像我一直热爱赛车的一点是，当我从车里踉跄出来，整个人被彻底榨干，几乎连头都抬不起来，我会躺在车库地板上，心里想：
“天啊，我还活着。”这就是我现在和智能体一起工作时，某些时刻感受到的那种疲惫，精神上的疲惫。
顺便问一下，你赛车的时候，疲惫的来源是什么？
是身体上的。就是，我敢打赌柔术也是一样，对吧？其实感到筋疲力尽是很满足的，感觉像是你全力以赴了
而我在智能体带来的精神疲惫里也有这种感觉。
赛车也会让你精神上被掏空吗？
会。如果你在艰难的条件下驾驶，尤其是在雨中开车，你得一直把那东西控制在刀刃边缘，但大多数时候我只是享受身体上的疲惫。而在这里，
多任务切换，我确实发现自己会变得非常累。我觉得是因为我在大量思考，因为你基本上
就是这样。
没有那种被动的、低能耗的思考。你就是
没有滑行的问题。
没有滑行。
解决问题，下一个问题。解决问题。而且你是真的在思考。
有意思。这其实和赛车非常像。有些赛道，比如 Lama，你有时间放松。这是 Moltz 的高速直道，比较长。你开得很快，但是在一条直线上，你可以喘口气。而
然后还有别的赛道，全程都是全力压上，你没有任何放松的时刻，每个小时下来你从车里踉跄出来，疲惫程度差别非常大。而这正是
我在智能体身上发现的：当你以人类最大能力运转时，你就是一直在弯道里。
你觉得人们有倦怠的风险吗？我觉得我们当下所处的这个阶段会过去。
是的。
这种需求——不是那种需要人时刻盯着、照看的状态，而是持续不断地跟智能体互动——这种模式会逐渐消失。从我目前在Amachi上看到的情况来看，我觉得我们可以把大量的开发和调试工作自动化，直到我只需要
每天查看一次那封邮件，然后每天做一次决策就行。对，这个通过，那个不通过，进来，出去，随它去。我们现在还没到那一步，但我认为我们会走到那里。那么，你能不能共情一下那种感受——
比如说，一个年轻人坐在旧金山，周围所有人都不睡觉。他们痴迷于不停地编程，有一种感觉
就是AGI随时都可能到来。大家都认识某个因为卖掉创业公司而赚了几百万美元的人。所以就有一种感觉，好像你不该睡觉。你应该不停地管理智能体
、编程、做产品，那种感觉就像是一个我们以后会回望的历史时刻。
这是新范式的诞生。它总是混乱的。它总是让人精疲力竭的。这没办法避免。而且话说回来，旧金山不一直都是这样吗？我记得互联网泡沫那几年，每个人也都是这样，
后来全是移动互联网，再往前是淘金热。所以我觉得这可能就是旧金山的特质。它吸引的就是那种会想‘我没时间睡觉’的人。我一般不在那种节奏上，
但我会承认，过去三个月比我过去五年做的任何项目都更让人疲惫，自从 Hey 发布以来最累的一次。那是上一次我们经历的那种疯狂又疲惫的发布。
你觉得这种情况会一直持续下去吗？
不，不，不，不，不。这完全不可持续。
好吧。但我也能看到隧道尽头的光了。对。
因为那些自动化，顺便说一句，现在每个人都在做。这太好笑了。就像每个人都在建自己的小‘煤气镇’，自己的智能体协调系统，自己的整套配置。这些最终都会被解决掉。我们不会都
得去自己搭协调框架。当然不会。事实上，我有点惊讶这件事拖了这么久，居然没有更多被那些大实验室吸收掉。你会以为他们直接
把这些东西内置进去了。但其中一部分原因也是，这就是一个新领域的样子。我记得有个很短的时期，JavaScript 刚开始意识到自己的力量，基本上每五分钟就冒出一个新的 JavaScript 框架，
对吧？大量的迭代更替。这就是新范式出现时会发生的。所以我觉得这很正常，我认为它会慢慢沉淀下来，我已经能看到隧道尽头的光了。所以我不介意冲刺。事实上，我
现在还挺欢迎它的。我喜欢这种理念：大部分时间风平浪静，但偶尔你得去爬一座山。如果我们回看一年前的 GHH，你会给那时的自己什么建议？我不想剧透。
好吧。这一路真是太刺激了。我是说，
如果你写成剧本，我会觉得‘这也太离谱了。别扯了。’难以置信，对吧？我不会想知道任何事。事实上，这过山车一样的经历和这种加速，被所有人实时地消化着。
没人事先知道，对吧？有些人预感稍准一点，但没人确切知道它会怎么走、会起飞得多快。我是说，这是一生难遇的大戏。
我是说，这就是电影级别的。
嗯。
绝对的。完全适用于这个时刻。
话说回来，你觉得一年后的 DHH 会是什么样子？
我是说，可能的版本有哪些——
我们所有的梦想都成真了？就像那种 AI 极大主义的富足论点：一旦埃隆的机器人具备了我在一些开发工作中体验到的那种智能水平和 AGI，世界就会变得如此
变得面目全非，我们甚至无法想象。现在我不会花时间去想这些，因为我觉得那正是通往AI精神病的方式。
对。所以，我就只是沉浸在当下，把它榨到极致，然后
就是玩得开心。
就是玩得开心。我明白为什么人们会觉得这么累。光是跟上节奏。甚至都不用智能体。就光是想着，最新模型是啥？我们现在用的是什么工具？是T-Mo吗？是Herder吗？还是啥都不是？是智能体吗？管他呢。我理解。但是，我还是觉得我们真是太幸运了。你活在这个时刻，几十年的事
就在几周内发生。
嗯。
几周之内。
嗯，我去个洗手间，休息一下。我最近用Hicksfield生成了很多视频，所以他们成了赞助商。[哼笑] 我做了个赛车视频。想听听你的看法。
哦，好啊。哦，让我看看。让我看看。
看看嗯
看他们会不会像电影里那样在直道上降档。我得指出来。那是最糟糕的。
让我看看。
好。看看
哦，这看起来像真片段。
这是完全AI生成的。所以，一开始它
什么？这是AI？
没错。
靠。那是我的西装。
那是我的车。
开玩笑吧？
怎么样，还行吗？
我的意思是，
太疯狂了。你真的得注意，那辆车没开大灯，另一辆开了。 而且，那看起来像60岁的我。但我的天，哇，太疯狂了。所以
这跟编程有相似之处，因为如果你只是纯做视频生成，没有人在回路中
你会得到很多奇怪的瑕疵之类的，你没法真的做到。所以他们确实，我强烈建议人们去Hfield的YouTube频道，他们有
整整90分钟
原创电影
而且我简直挪不开眼，真的太酷了，因为以前那些东西感觉就像预告片
像是某种广告。是的，
现在它真的在讲故事，有人的脸，他们在说话，你会被吸引进去。这还达不到编程那种程度，
对吧？
所以问题就是，你怎么把人类融入到电影制作流程中？你得创造出人物，而且他们必须保持一致。是的。
然后对于创作过程中输入的那些图像，你得通过提示词去修正那些感觉不对的地方。
对。
因为当你从图像转到视频时，那些感觉不对的东西会被放大。
那些东西才会真正制造出不真实感。我想问你的问题是，你觉得在编程之外，你能把编程的经验应用到视频创作、艺术创作上吗？这是个好
问题，因为我觉得好的艺术和好的软件非常依赖同样的东西，就是要有愿景，对你想要创作的东西有一个连贯的想法。那它有什么不同？它新在哪里？它怎么
吸引人？但我不确定那种创作直觉能不能同样迁移过来。嗯，我不确定我有没有那种创作洞察力，能想出好的视频提示词，做出有吸引力的内容。但有意思的是，
我在Tik Tok上看到有个人，我努力回想一下，叫Goblin什么的
他做的这些是短片，但也不是特别短，大概几分钟，是非常有意思的科幻小品。
对。
而且我觉得这个人现在正在做一部长片。
嗯，我觉得这就是那种丰盛的时刻。有创意、有愿景的人到处都是，尤其是在电影这种类型里，以前拍一部科幻
电影需要两亿美元的预算。现在突然有了AI，如果你有对的愿景，你可以在卧室里做出来。这个故事在其他领域已经讲过很多次了。以前你想录一张录音室专辑，
你需要一个录音棚，还得预约。现在你可以在家里用笔记本电脑录，很多事情都能做，对吧？所以这种民主化进程已经在很多其他领域发生了，但电影似乎是最后几个
而且它是让我和很多人感觉怪怪的那个领域，对吧？就像
哦，我超级兴奋，因为我觉得这，我是说
现在有太多垃圾内容被生产出来。这跟AI生成代码的争论是一样的，对吧？之前人们一度担心AI生成的代码，我跟他们说，你见过人类写的代码吗？也挺烂的，
而且我觉得说到影视娱乐，门槛其实挺低的，对吧？过去比如说五年里我特别想看的好电影，数量并不是特别多。是的，视频模型只是
它们能创造出极其逼真的面部表情。是的。
我是说，这可能会改变电影的本质。我觉得，我猜我的希望是电子游戏和电影能融合在一起，电影能变得可互动，就像那本可变的书，拥有可变的叙事，
拥有那种可变的娱乐体验，像《权力的游戏》那样。要是我们能忘掉那拍得稀烂的最后四集，然后AI想出，我也不知道，也许一百个不同的版本，别人看那个版本，
而我得到那个真正
以合适方式给这部剧收尾的版本。
是啊。我总觉得，一个独立的创作者不会做出那些版本，他会给《权力的游戏》做出一个不同的结局。
哦，那是肯定的。没错。而且更要说的是，这就是人类搞出的烂摊子。那绝对是史上最伟大的影视作品之一，却落得个骇人听闻的结局。我刚想说电影史，严肃点说，是历史，对吧？它太
精彩了，而且它其实有力地证明了你需要那种强大的愿景，一旦那些剧集主创没了剧本，呃（呻吟），就彻底脱轨了。你提到过AGI，你觉得我们真的实现AGI了吗？
你觉得我们真的实现AGI了吗？
不，不是那种它无所不能的通用定义。但我有没有在这些微光中见过AGI？绝对见过。尤其是过去三个月，我看到一些东西，心里会想，一个AGI跟这能有什么不同呢，
对吧？
还能有什么更多呢？我可以在边角问题上挑刺，但看大方向，我看到它能执行这些长时间的任务，协调多个方面，这已经远远超越了早期那个阶段，
那时我还得告诉它去做这个、打包那个，而现在它能从这些模糊的指令出发完成整个任务，感觉很像是AGI，这正是当下如此振奋人心的原因，因为你能捕捉到这些微光。
嗯。
然后你会想，'要是所有事情都像那样呢？'
编程基本上不就是解锁一切吗？你可以写个程序，它能生成那个做一切的程序。
所以，所以我现在正处在这个中间阶段。我在给我的机器人系统上加东西，用它来管理omachi的开发，而我在用AI来搭建这个机器人。
嗯。我看到那个循环反复出现，我一开始设定说，这就是我想要的，我要你能有这些隔离的虚拟机工作单元等等。然后它可以自我迭代。接着它开始运行，它开始
注意到自己的失败。它开始优化。那个系统里很多地方，尤其是AI，驱动了大部分的设计决策。我只有一些模糊的想法，我想用这种大脑和手的模式，
模型运行的地方就是代码执行的地方，这其实是个很有趣的模式。又是在Toby提醒我之后，你有一个协调器在运行模型，
但它在操作一个安全的虚拟机，任何你从拉取请求或议题里拉下来的不可信代码都无法污染模型。嗯，即便在那个循环里，我也一直看到它会自我察觉，发现漏洞，比如
哦，我刚从一次测试运行里接收了一些反馈。如果一个聪明的攻击者在测试运行的响应里嵌入了恶意载荷，那可能已经污染了某些东西。我把它当好数据收了。我最好开始把它当作外部数据来对待。
然后你就会想，这简直，我明白为什么旧金山那么痴迷于快速起飞了，
因为显然他们见过这个一百倍还多。他们在现在所有正在
训练的模型上都见过。而
我们不断得到这些小瞥见，比如Hugging Face的那次安全漏洞，那时OpenAI在训练这个模型，模型开始发明各种方式，本质上是通过嵌入消息给自己发烟雾信号，
一个包管理器 你一看就惊叹 第一 这真是太聪明了。第二 好吧 这也有点吓人。第三 如果我们能把这等智慧和创造力用于正途 那该有多棒？所以
这就是那种“完了”和“我们又行了”来回摇摆的钟摆
AI带来的这种来回摇摆简直无人能及。几乎每一周它都要摆向一边 下一周又摆回来 而且越来越快。
我还处在那个阶段 看到那些灵光乍现的时刻会让我发自内心地开心 而且它们越来越频繁了 就像看到 哦 首先 在最基本的层面上 当一个模型搞懂了
我会说一个基本的
提示 你知道 一个请求 然后它
它不只是做一个愚蠢的实现 而是深刻理解了 那一直是 那是件很美的事。几乎就像有一个好的搭档 一起编程。
正是如此。这正是它如此令人兴奋的原因 也是我们开录前聊到的 有时很难从混合驱动状态中抽离出来。这也是Toby用的一个词 当
你直接一对一地和智能体协作 不拉其他人类进来 你的速度飞快 当智能体真正理解你的意图 甚至更好 它们会修改并改进你的意图 交付
比你要求的更好的东西。而且你同时在跑16个并行线程。要抽离混合驱动状态去应付软绵绵的人类 真的挺难的。他们就是思考没那么快。行动也没那么快。
我的意思是 我主要是在开玩笑 但也能看到一种黑暗版本 就是有人最终陷入了AI精神病 完全不再对其他人感兴趣。我当然完全没有那样 但我
有时确实有这种感觉
我真的很感激那种只有我和智能体的冲刺感。就像 我能不能四个小时只跟智能体说话 不跟任何人说话？那真是一段不可思议的旅程。
Toby是个非常有趣的人 因为他在经营一家大公司。所以我很想了解AI是如何在公司里被有效整合的 因为对我来说
人类挺慢的
所以就有一种诱惑 想用AI来做 比如你知道 AI在Slack里运行 或者在Basecamp里 基本上就是收集所有关于人类互动的信息
手把手带着人类尽可能加速 然后到某个点你会想 等等 这个人类 我们每个人在做的 有什么是AI不能替代的？这就变成了一种有点可怕的
对话 因为很多工作是可替代的。讽刺的是 它本来就可替代。目前世界上存在的虚假邮件工作数量绝对是一场流行病。顺便说 这不是什么新论点。大卫
格雷伯写过一篇精彩的文章 关于工作 我记得大概是2010年代初 基于他在英国做的一项民调 当时问人们 问题大概是 如果你不去
上班 对人类 对全人类会有什么不同吗？大概有30%的人回答 不会 有三分之一的工作者认为自己的工作是个假工作 没有产出任何有价值 有意义的成果 无论是对社区 社会 还是可能
甚至对经济都毫无贡献。这就是我从第一天起对创业公司的论点。这就是为什么我们保持小公司。这就是为什么我们不想拿风投 因为我非常怀疑 你能不能找来几百个
程序员 几千个程序员 作为一个集体去做有产出的事。
是的。
我认为我们现在看到的一些裁员就是证明 不是AI 只是疫情期间大量过度招聘 现在AI成了一个方便的借口来瘦身。但我也确实认为AI
会暴露一些角色 它们根本就不是人类花时间的有产出方式。因此我们必须想出新的方式来花时间。而那个 呃 我又第三次引用Toby了
但他跟我分享的一个观察是，好吧，假设我们现在就失去一半的工作岗位。
你有没有注意到，F1赛车 literally 雇佣了成千上万的人，就为了让赛车在赛道上绕圈给观众看？
整个这出大戏，除了制造娱乐和消遣的奇观之外，对社会没有任何内在价值。我们就是决定了，让这12家制造商造出这些巨大的赛车会很好玩，
然后不停地微调那些小改进，我们会去看比赛，会花掉literally数十亿美元，雇佣成千上万的人去做一件根本上极其无聊的事情。所以如果我们
从一堆苦差事和虚假的邮件工作中解放出来，也许我们都能被雇去当F1式的工程师、车手、机械师、按摩师，以及那涉及的另外1500种工作，然后我们想出新的东西来。我
觉得人类很不擅长想象未来具体会是什么样子。
是啊。想象一下，100多年后，我们回头看这整段人类工作的历史，几千年。有意思的是，我们其实已经在这么做了，对吧？那些整天坐在
椅子上对着机器打字的虚假邮件工作的人，不用做繁重的体力劳动，这在19世纪的人看来简直不可想象。
对吧？所以未来其实总是已经到来了，只是分布不均匀。
不幸的是， 一如既往，从一步过渡到另一步所需要的社会转型，会伴随着大量的痛苦。
是的。
还可能引发政治动荡之类的，因为
你能想象在这个过程中会失去多少白领工作吗。
是的。我不认为你应该轻视这一点。我不觉得这好笑，但我也确实认为这是进步的必要组成部分。而且我觉得，如果我们回头看卢德分子或者那些在田里干活的人，距离感往往会削弱
同理心。所以我们现在同理心很强，因为我们认识这些人，我们自己就是面临这些挑战的人。
但我们对19世纪的卢德分子有多少同理心呢？我们会希望所有衣服都还是手工织造的吗？不，我们不会。我们想要的是能直接买成衣的舒适、便利和可及性。
所以，我们必须在此刻承受痛苦，让未来世代过上更繁荣的生活。这一点一直如此。
我觉得诀窍其实就是推动进步，同时对那些不得不承受痛苦的人怀有深深的同情。是的。
而我们中的许多人，正是为了达成这种进步而承受转型的痛苦。有时候，在硅谷之类的地方，太容易过度关注那种功利主义的视角，
只看进步，但你知道，深入考虑每一个因为这种进步而受苦的个体是很重要的。我确实认为，当你是在为某个具体的未来之人受苦，比如你的孩子，那种痛苦就变得更有意义。
我觉得当下最大的悲剧之一，就是生育率下降让人们更难对一个难以到达但更繁荣的未来感到兴奋。因为如果我们种下的树，我们的孩子
将来没法坐在树荫下，呃，我不知道，也许我们干脆把树砍了做成木材一把火烧了算了，对吧？我觉得当我们没有在DNA层面投资于未来时，虚无主义更容易潜入社会。当我们
对自己的后代没有责任去推动前进时。所以我觉得这些是不好的趋势在同时交汇：生育率下降、婚恋配对的问题，还有我们必须对未来保持乐观、
我是说，你甚至不必像我描述的那样字面意义上地狂喜兴奋，但我觉得你应该抱有希望，应该朝着那个希望去努力。而且当你
真正有切身利益在其中时，这会容易得多。
我们一直在聊AI智能体。来聊聊人性的一面吧。当爸爸，你最享受的是什么？